let's bring in Rich Eisen NFL Network
host and host of the Rich Eisen show on
DIRECTV's audience Network let me start
with you there rich does Antonio Brown
gets suspended I don't think he gets
suspended and I don't think he plays it
looks like they're doing this by
half-measure Dan which is not the way to
handle it I don't think but I don't
think you're gonna hear he's suspended
and I don't think he's gonna play
they're gonna figure out what what
designation that means like you know
coach's decision or it'll be a healthy
scratch question is is when does he come
back and then how do you put Humpty
Dumpty back together again and you know
look members of the team in the face and
say you know you don't get suspended but
you don't play if you curse out your
general manager you know at least that's
the way it looks right now obviously
there's lots between now and when toe
meets ball on Monday night but and I
know you've got victi fur on at the top
of your next hour and he's got more
boots on the ground than I do but from
everything that I'm hearing it sounds
like they're trying to just just take
the air out of the ball here and and
figure out a way how and Tonio brown
could stay on this team because he's so
damn talented does Antonio Brown need
the Raiders or do the Raiders need
Antonio Brown more hmm the Raiders need
a Antonio they need them yeah and and
Antonio Brown needs the Raiders to make
the amount of money that he can make I
mean you know I know everybody's already
speculating you know that the minute
that Brown gets released he'll go to the
Patriots yeah you know I had Urlacher on
my show too yesterday and he said he'll
just go to the Patriots because they fix
everybody and he's you know I laugh
because that's the that's you know
that's the way it all goes and it
sounded funny last night in that in that
points challenged Bears loss cordarrelle
Patterson was used by the Bears in a
short yardage situation in a holding
penalty got called on top of a loss of
yards and a Mike isn't that odd how
something that worked so well for the
Patriots suddenly doesn't work well for
other team
so you know Antonio Brown might go on to
another team sure if he is released but
he's not getting paid the guaranteed
dollars that he would be paid if he
stays on Oakland so he needs the Raiders
to be paid to have his business boom the
way he wants and the Raiders you know I
don't think they need him in order to to
you know I don't think they're winning a
Super Bowl this year but they need him
to evaluate Derek Carr if that's
something that Gruden really wants to do
and and Gruden seems to love evaluating
quarterbacks every single day so so I
guess that that's my answer to that
question what was the big question that
was answered last night in the
bears-packers game there wasn't a single
one I guess can Pinero make a catch I
guess I you know I I don't know what to
make of the the Packers offense at all
and you know it just seems that that was
the first preseason game for for both of
those teams I mean neither true Biscay
or or Rodgers threw a pass in the month
of August and you know normally when we
wring our hands over the preseason and
and how insignificant it is or how to
significant it is when somebody gets
hurt and that that conversation usually
goes away when the playing season starts
we'll see what happens Sunday to see if
we have similar games like the one we
had last night where that felt like a
preseason game it looked like it it
looked like a team that was running
through a new offense for Green Bay for
the first time with their quarterback in
any real game situation and the Bears
looked like they hadn't thrown a pass
with Drew Biscay yet and I know it's
still the same cast but you also have to
get credit to the Packers defense yeah I
mean if you saw Aaron Rodgers came up
and gave Mike Pettine at the defensive
coordinator and attaboy shove in the
chest when sure Biscay was sacked for
the last time they that that might be
the story of the night the best matchup
the matchup you're looking forward to
seeing the most this weekend is one well
I mean the obvious one is Sunday night
with Giants cowboys right behind it
for various reasons with the Cowboys
woodsy getting paid like that and and
Eli's first start in in a season with
daniel Jones sitting there - Odell and
say Quon being owned by every fantasy
team in the nation but the one that's
kind to - they're under the radar are
Rams at at Panthers that's going to be
dynamite and Chiefs of jaguars I know
there's a lot of people on the Jaguars
train and we haven't seen Nick Foles at
all four Nets lost weight the defense is
healthy and hungry and the Chiefs have
all those weapons and the one thing I
want to see what the Chiefs is defense
you know Tyron Matthew's been added on
the back end Frank Clark I believe it's
an upgrade over D Ford and it's Steve
spagnolo coordinating it and that is not
an easy assignment for Kansas City to go
in and week one it's all gonna rich
highs an NFL Network host and of course
host of the Rich Eisen show you can see
that following this show on audience
network channel 239 heading up to the
mothership today we have a town hall so
I'm up there with Mike Tirico Chris
Berman Bob Lee Robin Roberts and I guess
yeah we're answering questions is
anybody want me to say hi - that's you
know I I don't know Dan you know I've
looked in my mailbox at work - I looked
in the mail but I've got two jobs you
know it with mailboxes and didn't get
that it didn't know I might be the place
where the last 15 espy Award invitations
got some do when when's the last time
you were at the mothership I have not
been there since the day I left and the
day I left was just a regular day I did
Sports Center one of the last days of
May of 3 had a couple days left on my
contract went to my apartment in New
York City that I had just his crash in
spot is getting married two weeks later
by the way McLovin Dan was at my wedding
it is true
and as a matter of fact Dan was not only
at my wedding he went behind the bar and
served Jagermeister shots to people that
is true
that's fact these are all facts we were
in Central Park now part of the reason
why I went I love rich and his wife
Susie but it was in Central Park it was
beautiful moat house I mean it was a
house in Central Park yeah and it was
one of those things where you know you
and your family take pictures after the
the ceremony itself and so you're misty
the you know ice appetizer portion of
the evening and I come out of the
picture area and a couple buddies in
minor like you have no idea what's going
on at the bar my wife and Patrick is
serving like Chris Fowler Jagermeister
shots and Saudi rate yeah yeah so III
finished my final SportsCenter had a
couple days left on my contract and I
got a call from my agent saying that he
just received a fax from ESPN saying the
negotiations were over and and we were
done I'm like what do you mean we're
done we got like 48 hours left know that
we're done and then 10 minutes later I
got a call from USA Today asking for
comment ESPN at leaked that I had been
not renewed was the word it was called
and and the rest is history
maybe and I don't know so you tell me
what's going on at the mothership today
I don't know I'm just I was invited I'm
on a panel and a panel who's moderating
the panel I don't know I don't know who
the moderator is but I think that I'll
just be shaking my head grinning and
laughing and listening to Chris Berman
stories well you deserve it they look
you and uh that's a hell of a panel
right there all the greats were invited
so Larry Beil bill Peters well you know
my own 40th celebration on the show
today Dan oh you are yes I am my third
our guest all third hour I haven't seen
him in a very long time mr. Craig
Kilborn is coming
my show courting producer Don Bowie just
strolled into our green room area here
to wash out the newly purchased martini
mixer is we're gonna make our own drinks
and give a toast to the fortieth
celebration that neither of us were
invited to well he'll be coming out of
his cave on the program yeah he's the
Howard Hughes of Sports Center I'll let
you know if he's cut his fingernails but
I mean his Instagram account is dynamite
yeah I know I don't know how on
Instagram you are but I mean there's
some old-school Kilby like dissolves and
Larry Bird highlights and it's it's
classic it's classic so that'll be
coming up after this show riches show on
DirecTV on in central channel 239 thanks
for joining us rich have a great weekend
we'll be watching you know before I go
Dan the other day Kyle Brant came on my
show from good morning football and
brought up his favorite sports center
commercial being the one where I got
sent down to the minors James came Hulk
James cope yes I had the James Cape poke
spirit and I told him the story about
how that almost didn't happen because I
was legitimately upset about being the
sports center anchor chosen to be sent
down to the minors and I remember and
one radicular SportsCenter anchor pulled
me aside to basically snap out of it and
just go ahead and do it suck it up and
be part of a funny Sports Center ad and
that that guy was Dan Patrick Thank You
wrench I actually tried to bump you I
try to get somebody else in hold yes you
tell Kilby I said hello and we'll be
watching Thank You Bonjour the date
taker all right that's Rich Eisen from
NFL Network for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]